Carol King wrote the song You've Got a
Friend she did and she wrote it she told
me later that you know in Fire and Rain
rate says I've seen lonely times and I
could not find a friend she wrote You've
Got a Friend as a sort of response to
that song which I that's mind-blowing
Carol King who you you love you put it
out Carol puts it out on her album yes
you're the guy who wins the Grammys for
it you won all the awards yours goes to
like it goes through the roof it becomes
a huge hit
pissed because she's probably like hey I
write songs for other people too but you
got all of the accolades for this song I
did I I uh and today it's still overseas
and and uh you know when I play in sort
of remote territories it's the song
people know me for yeah can you give us
a little of that sure all right sure
[Music]
thank you
when you're down
in trouble
and you need love and care
and nothing
oh nothing's going right
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
see you again
Winters bring some revolts
all you got to do is calling
and I will be there yes I'll be there
friends
[Music]
if the sky high above you
should turn dark and full of clouds
when should begin to blow
foreign
[Music]
to see you again
his winter spring summer of all
you got to do is
[Music]
I'll be there
who got a friend when people can be so
cold
they'll hurt you yes send it search up
they're gonna take your soul if you let
them on
don't you let them
you just call out my name again and you
know wherever I am
I'll come running just as fast as I can
to see you again
oh yes it don't you know about that
winter spring
Summerall fall
oh all you got to do is call me
I won't be there I will be there
You've Got a Friend
[Music]
Got a Friend
any good to know that you've got a
friend
okay friend talk friends
you got a friend
foreign
[Music]
1971 that's released to radio stations
and you know what radio stations really
had a hard time they had to figure out
whether to play your version or Carole
King's version well it was like this
unbelievable treasure they had both of
these versions
foreign